hello everyone we're facing a bit of a
conundrum here with my podcast and at
the daily wire in general I have an
interview with Kelly J Keene otherwise
known as Posey Parker that we want to
offer to everyone
um we're quite convinced that it will be
taken down by YouTube and so what we've
done is offering we're offering an
edited version on the YouTube platform
now if you want to watch the unedited
version then you can go to the Daily
wire Plus or you can go to Spotify or
any of the other podcast producers and
Distributors that that haven't had such
a heavy hand on the Forbidden front
let's say we don't know if this is a
good solution you know I feel in part
that it would be better just to say to
hell with it not put it up on YouTube at
all but then people don't watch it or to
put up the unedited version and to take
our lumps but we're afraid we'll be
taken out entirely on the YouTube front
as a consequence and so we're trying
this as a interim solution and so
hopefully you'll be on board with that
solution if you want to watch the
interview with Kelly J Keane Parker
Posey on YouTube and it's somewhat
slightly edited form then please feel
welcome to do so otherwise head over to
the other platforms where you can watch
the whole thing
thanks very much for your time and
attention
if we think about a hospital in America
right now
um you know sedating somebody getting
ready for a double mastectomy in their
teens it's I can't leave it like I can't
stop until it stops yeah nothing would
persuade me I don't think to to stop
because the more people tried to stop me
the more I think I'm I'm right and I'm
on the right path and it has to be done
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening
today I have the privilege of speaking
with women's rights activist Kelly J
Keane also known as Posey Parker we
discuss the co-opting and invading of
women's spaces the hatred jealousy and
attraction toward what women naturally
possess which underlies the transgender
movement
the rise of false compassion as a means
to censor and control
what Posey Parker aims to accomplish
with her let women speak events
and how social pressure ideologically
captured police and terrorizing mobs
have not and will not silence her thank
you very much for agreeing to talk to me
today Kelly J
um
tell me about the name Parker Posey
first
so when I was expecting one of my babies
that was there were two names on our
list
um Posey and Parker and so when I
joined an online Forum I just used those
as a Anonymous name and it stuck
but I go with my real name these days I
see okay and so do you wanna maybe you
could let everybody uh who's watching
listening know a little bit about you
um
and I don't know much about you I've
read your you your Wikipedia page and
done some background research as well um
you you sound like quite the monster
when you read your Wikipedia page but
it's a Wikipedia page so uh you know
that's that that has to be taken with
the requisite grain of salt and we can
go through that I mean I it's quite
interesting for example that you're
described as an anti-transgender rights
activist that's pretty convenient for
the people who don't like what you're
saying right that you're an
anti-transgender rights activist the
left you got to give the leftist
radicals a certain amount of credit for
being able to warp language like
nobody's business so but but who are you
and why are you doing what you're doing
so I am a mother of four and a happily
married woman
um I've been with my husband for 25
years and then in 2015 this issue came
along I was a full-on labor voting Lefty
and uh I joined an online Forum of women
and then loads of men started populating
it and unlike the women who actually
were completely ineffective in their
campaigning uh unlike the men uh women
weren't talking about themselves what
they looked like they weren't posting
photos but these men did and they were
really masculine looking men with wigs
and
sort of 1980s secretary looks and uh I
just asked one of them one day are you
really identify as a woman and the
vitriol from him was bad enough but from
other women was just astounding uh and I
just thought well I'm not allowed to
talk about this so I want to talk about
this and I'm not having anybody telling
me that I can't talk about something so
significant
and then I just started uh 2018 I put a
billboard up with a dictionary
definition of the word woman
and that really sort of solidified my
place in this movement yeah the
billboard that was uh adult human female
yeah
hateful
yeah well that's pretty yeah yeah okay
so you said a couple of things there
that I found interesting so that
um
the first was that
you asked one of these men who was in
This Woman's Forum whether or not he
identified as a woman and received a lot
of hate and vitriol in response so well
first question is do you feel that you
crafted your question in a manner that
might have invited that sort of response
or what other explanation do you have
for it and then the second thing you
said which I think is equally relevant
is that not only did you see receive a
lot of vitriol from the person to whom
you directed the question but you
received excess vitriol from women
and so
first of all let's inquire into the
question that you posed to see if there
was anything provocative about it and
second I'd like to hear your thoughts on
why
you have experienced the fact that women
are very likely to jump on this
particular bandwagon for example
and provide
uh noisy and self-righteous support for
the people that you are hypothetically
pillory so let's start with the question
like do you feel that you asked a fair
question and of this of this particular
man
I actually don't think I asked a
question and that's because my knowledge
in 2023 means I think it probably wasn't
provocative enough I think I should have
basically not asked the question do you
identify but just told him that he
wasn't a woman and it was insulting to
pretend to be one
um so yeah I it was the wrong question
but I've learned a lot since then uh as
for women I think I'm supposed to say as
a women's rights campaigner that women
are um
oppressed under the patriarchy and
therefore they're just trying to
struggle to get their place at the table
and I don't think it's that I think it's
currency and I think the reason women
compete in who can be the quickest to
give women's rights away is because then
they have currency of being these really
nice people and and I think women are uh
often use psychological warfare and
ostracizing and niceness shall we say as
a strategy to to win against other women
so that's why I think women do that
in a world filled with uncertainties
it's crucial to be ready for whatever
comes your way whether it's a natural
disaster a sudden emergency or
unforeseen circumstances having a
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the assurance
that you and your loved ones will be
well taken care of right now my Patriot
Supply is offering 25 off a three-month
food supply to help you stay prepared
for anything go to preparewithjordan.com
and grab this special price before it
ends your three-month emergency food
supply provides over 2 000 calories each
day for optimal strength and energy in
stressful situations you can enjoy a
wide variety of my Patriot Supply and
can customize your supply they offer an
ultimate breakfast kit a mega protein
kit with real meat and even a
gluten-free kit the best part is each
meal is delicious and has a shelf life
of 25 years don't wait for disaster to
strike before taking action invest in
your safety and well-being by securing
your food storage today go to
preparewithjordan.com and get 25 off
your three-month emergency supply go to
repairwithjordan.com right now let's
prepare with jordan.com
well two things about that so
there is a pattern of anti-social
Behavior among women that's been well
documented in the relevant psychiatric
research and so anti-social men
tend to use to devolve towards physical
violence but anti-social women use
gossip malicious slander and reputation
savaging
and so that's been documented for
decades and that's the female pattern of
anti-social Behavior but you tied it
into something
you tied it into currency you know and
so I want to tell you a little story so
I interviewed this very deep religious
thinker his name is Matthew pajo and he
wrote a book called what is it the
sacred all remember momentarily
um
it's about Genesis and I talked to him
about the sin of Eve
in the in the story of the Garden of
Eden
and
it's a sin of Pride right it leads to
the fall and the sin of pride is that
Eve
proclaims that it's something like she
can even clasp the serpent to her breast
the poisonous serpent so imagine that it
is the case that women are caregivers
and especially caregivers of infants and
that their ability to provide care is
one of their true strengths but it's
also a potential source of status and so
a woman who wants to make a false and
prideful status claim can claim that her
maternal Embrace is so all encompassing
that even the serpents can be included
right now the next thing of course that
happens is Adam
hearkens to her
claim and I think what happens there is
that
men will enable women by telling them
that their desire to embrace even the
poisonous is laudable and that the
social structure which is what Adam's
responsible for say in the Genesis Story
the social structure can be modified to
accommodate to their wish of course that
precipitates the fall all of that and so
you said the reason this I brought this
up is because you said your conclusion
has been that the women who are
defending the indefensible
which would be let's say the mail claim
that
femininity female hood is merely
subjective identification that women are
claiming to support that because they
want to obtain currency okay so why have
you become convinced of that and what
exactly do you mean by that I I just
think it becomes I guess status is part
of it but I think
I think everybody does something for
self-serving reasons and I think by a
process of elimination I can't think why
I just can't think why else a woman
would do it and I've thought about it a
lot you know I've already tried to think
like what is in it for someone who says
yeah your 16 year old daughter can share
his face with a man getting undressed
you know how how else could it be
justified besides some sort of
self-serving motive and I think it just
comes to currency that they can they can
maybe pretend that they don't have these
feelings which
may just be heaps of cognitive
dissonance but I just don't buy it I
think it's dishonest I don't buy it that
somebody who's experienced any female
only space where men have entered and
most of us women have and what happens
in those moments is we breathe quietly
we wait until the threat is gone and we
understand it before I can rationalize
it I understand it as a threat and I
just don't buy that other women don't do
that so they must have self-serving
motives you said when we first started
our discussion that you know several
years ago
within the span of a decade you were a
card-carrying member of the labor party
and that your political ideology was
tilting towards the left and I suppose
the classic leftist rejoinder to what
you just said was that no you've just
developed an unreasonable Prejudice on
behalf of that's directed towards the
poor oppressed marginalized trans men
let's say the men who are claiming to be
women and that all that happened to you
was that you reached the limits of your
tolerance and that your genuine
Prejudice was revealed and that you're
rationalizing the emergence of that
prejudice by gaslighting the women who
are generally compassionate about the
marginalized and the reason I'm
formulating the question like this is
because you you were or are I don't know
which
um on the left politically and the left
historically has been
um
at least in principle campaigning for
the rights and the inclusion of the
dispossessed and so
look Kelly I've gone to to Washington
several times and talked to
Democrats in the house and in the Senate
and I did the same with Robert Kennedy a
lot when I interviewed him recently and
I always ask them the Democrats that I
meet the same question and that is
when does the left go too far and I I've
never received an answer to that
question
you know and they ask me at reverse and
I always say well I think they go too
far when they push for Equity because
that's equality of outcome and that's
complete bloody disaster and their
response uniformly is no no no they just
mean equality of opportunity which they
most decidedly don't but you were or are
on the left and and maybe we can delve
into that a little bit but for some
reason you appear to be proclaiming and
do believe that there's something false
about the compassion that's being
manifested at least in this particular
case what is that how do you square that
with your original leftist
presuppositions and how do you
distinguish genuine compassion for the
marginalized and and oppressed from
whatever it is that you're objecting to
now
well I think I had a journey shall we
say in this X Factor World in which we
live
um where I realized that I was being
lied to about this
and then I realized that what
independent was a total hatred and
dismissive
um attitudes to towards women and our
fears and the reality of Our Lives
um and you know wider and potentially
more important but for me I'm a women's
rights campaigner but also a disregard
of the truth
um in favor of a point of view an
ideology some sort of power
um that's handed over to these people so
it was at that moment that I then have
to really question because I'd be a fool
if not to
why else do I believe the things I
believe and are they true do they really
exist and the answer I came up with was
categorically no they're not
um is it true that the left is less
misogynist than the right absolutely
categorically not
um the Trade union movements like when
you look at those in the UK they didn't
really care about women's workers rights
and I don't mean gender pay gaps or any
ethereal kind of Concepts that we can
discuss in 2023 whether we agree with
them or not and I think you and I are
probably closer to agreeing on that it
doesn't really exist
um but yeah it just it just made me
think were the left always like this and
I was just stupid and naive or have they
really dramatically changed
and I haven't answered that question
funny because maybe I just don't want to
admit that I've been stupid most of my
life but no I can't possibly I don't
think I don't think women right now with
this ideology and nobody really standing
up for us I don't think we can place our
flag in any political Camp
well you know I worked for a leftist
political party when I was a kid that
was a long time ago from the time I was
14 to the time I was 17 and
the I got to know the wife of the leader
of the Socialist Party in my home
province of Alberta and I liked her a
lot she was a librarian from our local
junior high school and uh me and all the
other delinquencies to go out during
recess and lunch hour and go hang out in
the library and bother Mrs naughtly and
we did that partly because she treated
us like adults and I did it partly
because she used to give me things to
read and she gave me a lot of great
books to read and she was the first
person who really introduced me to
Serious literature and I got to know her
and her husband so that kind of gave me
privileged access to the stratospheres
of the labor party the Socialist Party
the NDP in Canada and I met a lot of the
leaders and this was back in
1977 about 77 so a long time ago and uh
you know I found a lot of them admirable
I thought they were they were often
labor leader types you know Union types
and they had done a fair bit to give the
working class in Canada a voice and
they'd emerged out of farmers
cooperatives in Saskatchewan and so that
seemed to be like a genuine
political movement and a Genuine Voice
for those who were shot out of the
political process the conservative party
at that time was clearly the party of
big business and sort of unashamedly so
and the liberal party was in the middle
but the NDP they had admirable people in
them you know but I watched the
activists back then and they really
bothered me I thought they were
resentful and bitter and whiny and
narcissistic and that was eventually why
I stopped working with the NDP and that
was in 1979 I guess so I would say I
don't think the left has always been
like this you know I I think that the
working class needed a political voice
and I think that's still true now
whether they can find it on the left or
not now I don't think they can but I
don't think that you were merely blind
your entire life and that the left has
always been pathological but I do think
that compassion is the best camouflage
for narcissistic serpents and so if the
left proclaims itself
as the party of the oppressed then it
opens up the door to being invaded by
those who will use claims of compassion
to put forward their narcissistic what
would you clamoring and groping for
power and one of the problems with being
on the left is that it's very hard for
Liberal types to draw boundaries
and so you risk you risk being invaded
by
the real predators and I I really think
in some ways that's what's happened to
the left is that the narcissists have
invaded and they now Dominate and this
is an age-old story right this is this
is a danger to this has been a danger to
organizations since since the dawn of
time and it's certainly happening now so
I don't think it was a complete
existential uh catastrophe you know what
you believed but
but I do think that that inability to
draw distinctions on the left is is is
potentially fatal
so
where do you find how do you
conceptualize yourself now I I think I
pointed out that if you read your
Wikipedia page then what you are
apparently is an anti-transgender rights
activist and that sounds like a pretty
damn reprehensible sort of person
because I mean here's these poor
marginalized transgender uh men let's
say who are just trying to struggle
forward you know what would you say
bravely as President Biden would say and
a world hell bent on their oppression
and genocide and there you are you know
opposing their rights and so what's your
this is a horrible thing to ask but
what's your self-definition
oh I struggled with it on a daily basis
it's so fluid um I'm just an adult human
female I'm a mother I'm a wife I'm a
subject of the United Kingdom I'm just a
a person but it's just so I'm just not
having it that that
um these men are vulnerable like if you
feel vulnerable you don't want to be uh
and you you genuinely feel that the
world hates you so very much I don't
know why you put on women's clothes to
leave the house I mean it's just I'm
just not having such a nonsensical silly
uh ideology taking over what my spaces
look like and the spaces of my daughter
so I I call myself a women's rights
activist because I believe that women's
language I mean so much
uh goes back to that word woman and what
it means and who can use it uh and we
are now debating what sex means in the
equality act which is just
fundamentally
just ridiculous we know what sex means
and now we're having to re-clarify what
it means in law
um in our sort of in our rights act so
that women can have spaces and I for me
the equality Act is a nonsense anyway I
I digress slightly on this but for me
the equality Act is not is just doesn't
make any sense because surely a
proportionate reason and that's one of
the things you need to justify a woman
only space or a women only group is
proportionate means well
um if I say I just want women in my
groups and that's proportional
uh if I said I just wanted women on my
board of a company maybe not so but if I
say that I just want a social group
that's women only for women
um I don't know why I need to justify
keeping a man out who says he's a woman
and then it goes back to the gra and I'm
sure we'll get on to that but I
fundamentally think having a legal
fiction in this country is is
preposterous and has led to all of the
Fallout we now see
um if we were tolerant we'd just let
these men do what they like call
themselves whatever they like uh stay
out of women's spaces and just all get
on with our days
the Bible is the root of all wisdom
inspiration and spiritual nourishment
the Hallow app empowers you to explore
the Bible's profound teachings and to
effortlessly incorporate them into your
daily life
a great place to start while you deepen
your understanding of the Bible is to
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year available on the Hello app for
brief daily readings and Reflections
here you can dive into an extensive
library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and audio guided meditations whether
you're a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey hallow provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before
studying the Bible's literary Brilliance
has influenced countless writers poets
and artists throughout history by
studying the Bible yourself you'll gain
a deeper appreciation for the power of
Storytelling symbolism and metaphor
enriching your understanding of
literature across different genres the
Hallow app also helps you connect with a
community of like-minded individuals
sharing experiences insights and
encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hollow.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along
the way enrich your education and
nurture your mind and soul today
download the Hallow app at hallow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan
hello.com Jordan for an exclusive
three-month free trial of all ten
thousand plus prayers and meditations
so there's a lot of issues that you just
brought up there yes the the well I
would like I would like if you would to
explain for those who are watching and
listening a little bit more about the
equality act and then maybe we can turn
to this issue of
I think I think it's a hatred and
jealousy of women it's a hatred jealousy
and attraction to what women
hypothetically have that's part of the
what would you say Nexus of
Psychopathology that's driving this
desire to
to uh to tread on the grounds of women's
rights to to appropriate the domain of
femininity that's so this is cultural
appropriation and its most fundamental
sense anyways let's start with the
equality act will you bring everybody
watching and listening up to speed about
that
so there are different characteristics
might be disability religion freedom of
religion and freedom from religion
um uh sexual orientation gender
assignment so when that started that
used to be oh sorry gender reassignment
so that would that used to be
transsexuals and what they did is they
made it so vague and opaque that they
could revise what gender reassignment
actually meant so you could be protected
uh to what extent I I'm not actually
sure but you can't be discriminated
against for having gender reassignment
well
I think there are elements there are
points at which it would be
inappropriate for example
um we do have bra fitters in the UK who
now have got jobs so men who don't have
much surgery who call themselves women
now our bra fitters in
in large shops so
um and you're skeptical of that I take
it there's nowhere well look I'm I'm a
prude British so there's very few uh
chances I would take to go and get
profiting anyway but certainly if it was
a
if it was a man I a person I would call
a man I.E an actual man
um then I wouldn't do it and also I've
been you know I've got a teenage
daughter you go for a first bra fitting
it's incredibly embarrassing and to hear
a male voice in that space would be
horrendous because as we know girls when
they develop through puberty it's the
most embarrassing time and also the time
when they most need to fit in with their
peers and so those two things are really
hideous anyway
um but anyway I digress so the equality
Act is a balance of uh different rights
based upon different characteristics
um and
at the moment in their in the um
Westminster Hall debate yesterday
uh there was a debate on whether or not
the equality act when it talks about sex
even though we've got gender
reassignment in the equality act now sex
is opposed to according to people mainly
on the left include men who call
themselves women which then makes the
whole thing pretty damn laughable if sex
in our law in our legal system actually
means someone who says they're a
particular sex as opposed to someone who
is a particular sex and I I just I just
think this is where we are we have a gen
for example we have a gender recognition
um act which means that you can change
your gender but there is no such thing
as gender throughout most of our laws
um that that actually has any definition
and it's the same in the states I should
imagine it's the same in Canada where
they've flooded all of our laws that
actually are reliant on biological sex
they flooded with the word gender so
therefore it becomes mixed up and then
you can pretend all along you just meant
people who identify as one sex or
another so you know for me the equality
Act is is a little dated now and I think
very confusing anyway and I think we
need to rip it up and start all over
again okay so on the on the bra fitting
question let's say so why isn't the
proper response to your concerns
well it's the Modern Age
um we've already dispensed almost all
together with men only spaces
um it's now time to do the same to
female only spaces and maybe the right
attitude for you and your daughter is to
just get over your prudishness and to
accept the fact that
people who want to do something
including bra fitting can do it
regardless of their sex or their gender
so why would you you you appear to
reject that proposition and why why do
you think that so two questions I guess
why do you think it's appropriate for
you to reject that claim and and for you
and on behalf of your daughter let's say
and then there's a thornier question
underneath that which is well under what
conditions is discrimination which by
the way used to mean judgment as well as
any any number of other things what are
the situations under which
discrimination actually becomes not only
appropriate but say ethically mandated
and this is a conversation we haven't
had in our culture for and I would say
this is the fault of the left although
the right Wingers have enabled it by
being so hapless yeah we haven't had a
discussion about what constitutes
appropriate discrimination for you know
since like 1964. it's a very long time
so first of all why do you think you're
justified in your phobia there we go and
your phobia about going to have a bra
fitting with a man who claims to be a
woman
well I think it I think if Society had
moved on to a point where women and men
weren't uncomfortable uh naked around
each other if there was no such thing as
sexual assault if there was no such
thing as like low-level sexual assault
which is voyeurism and indecent exposure
which is an opportunist crime and we
know that most of the people that would
do that will be men and most of the
victims will be women and children so I
think in in that regard if that had
changed and that had that no longer
existed then maybe I would be open to
listening but we know that men and women
don't particularly like to be undressed
in front of each other and if you're in
the UK that includes everybody whatever
sex they are
um we're relatively prudish I'm quite
happy to be so but you know I just I
just think we're we have naked bodies
and we have boundaries around those sort
of naked bodies and in situations where
women feel more uncomfortable and in a
state of undress and and I know that
boys feel like that too
um around uh the opposite sex at certain
stages of their lives if not all of
their lives and so I think
um that's why I mean we sort of joke
about this question and uh but we both
know that that question is asked it's a
it's a genuine sort of
um question from the left when you
ordered from trans activists when you
speak about this and my first
uh question used to be um does my 11
year old daughter have the right to be
in a female only space and not see an
adult penis and I would ask that in
female only labor women groups online
and I was told no she's transphobic
you're raising a bigot why is your
daughter staring at genitals is she a
pervert you know and and well and and
you you know that that's also a good
place to observe as well that that issue
of currency that you just described also
rears its hideous head at that point
it's like it's a competition between the
women that you're talking about to see
who can virtue signal the loudest about
their loving kindness and tolerance and
that becomes monstrous and devouring
when taken Beyond a certain point that's
certainly what Freud observed for
example when he wrote extensively about
the edible complex because what we're
seeing in the culture right now is the
edible complex gone mad on a scale that
would I'm sure is making Freud rotate in
his coffin at about 150 you know 150
spins per second
[Music]
thank you